so und wir nutzen die zeit und schauen
schon mal auf der nächste
tagesordnungspunkt um die
unionsrechtlichen vorgaben im
umsatzsteuerrecht das dürfte besonders
land und forstwirtschaftliche
betriebsleiter interessieren denn es
gibt eine besondere ein besonders
steuerprivileg für landwirte und zwar
diejenigen
die unter
600.000 60.000 euro gewinn im jahr
machen die sind von der umsatzsteuer vor
erklärung
befreit das heißt sie müssen eben nicht
eine umsatzsteuererklärung abgeben und
monatlich oder vierteljährlich abschläge
zahlen es gibt es schon seit 1960 er
jahren und sie können auch ihre
umsatzsteuer pauschalieren das bedeutet
wenn sie etwas verkaufen setzen sie
pauschal 10,7 prozent umsatzsteuer an
können das geld behalten und dieses geld
soll eben die gezahlte umsatzsteuer
erstatten wenn sie einkäufe
tätigen nun soll dieser
umsatzsteuersatz allerdings auf
9,7 prozent gesenkt werden als erstes
spricht dazu till mansmann von der
präsident die kolleginnen und kollegen
erlauben sie mir ja als erster redner in
dieser debatte erst einmal das thema
kurz umreißen
in der umsatzsteuerpauschalierung die
der gesetzgeber land und
forstwirtschaftlichen betrieben unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen die auch
gerade noch einmal angepasst wurden
gewährt erkennt die eu-kommission
unzulässige beihilfen und unser eigener
bundesrechnungshof sagt uns dass diese
einschätzung nicht von der hand zu
weisen ist da die eu kommission bereits
ein vertragsverletzungsverfahren wie
auch ein beihilfeverfahren
eingeleitet hat drohen erhebliche
prozessrisiken und rückforderungen
insbesondere zum schaden der betroffenen
landwirtschaftlichen betriebe der jetzt
nur noch geschäftsführend im amt
befindlichen bundesregierung ist es in
den letzten vier jahren nicht gelungen
sich auf eine anpassung der
pauschalierung so zu einigen dass die
gefahren die den verfahren auf
europäischer ebene droht deutlich
entgegen tritt es ist jetzt einfach so
wenn wir die möglichkeit der
pauschalierung grundsätzlich erhalten
wollen was die bürokratie bei den
betroffenen betrieben genauso wie für
unsere finanzverwaltung reduziert und
dabei die verfahrens risiken deutlich
begrenzen wollen müssen wir noch in
diesem jahr also noch vor der bildung
der neuen bundesregierung also heute
dieses gesetz verabschieden wir müssen
den satz den die betriebe in rechnung
stellen können von 10,7 auf 3,5 prozent
senken wir die sogenannte ampel parteien
haben nun dieses vorhaben das die große
koalition in vier jahren nicht
hingekriegt hat pragmatisch umgesetzt
wir legen dieses gesetz nun vor das hat
kompromisse erfordert nicht mit allem
sind wir freie demokraten wirklich
glücklich die fristen sind alle jetzt
sehr knapp die jährlich fällige
neuberechnung weiß systematisch
schwächen auf bei der ersten lesung
dieses gesetzes um in das
sachverständigen anhörung anfang dieser
woche haben sie geschätzte kollegen der
union auf einige probleme mit recht
hingewiesen die wir auch sehen im
hauptausschuss gab es dazu von ihnen
jetzt keine weiteren fragen
ich gehe also davon aus dass sie heute
hier zu stimmen weil sie das
prozessrisiko ähnlich wie wir
einschätzen mit fehleinschätzungen der
europäischen rechtslage haben sie
arbeitet erfahrungen gesammelt
die änderungs und entschließungsanträge
der anderen oppositions fraktionen
lehnen wir ab weil sie gerade die
prozessrisiken nicht ausreichend
berücksichtigen wir sorgen jetzt dafür
dass den landwirtschaftlichen betrieben
die möglichkeit der pauschalierung
erhalten bleibt das sorgen dafür dass
sie europa rechtskonform ausgestaltet
wird und damit zukunftssicher gemacht
wird und wir sorgen dafür und das ist
uns freien demokraten gerade vor dem
hintergrund erkannten schwächen sehr
wichtig dass die künftige festsetzung
des satzes in einem jährlichen formellen
gesetzgebungsverfahren durchgeführt wird
der bundestag bleibt damit herr des
verfahrens genauso wie es zahlreiche
sachverständige bei der
sachverständigenanhörung am 15.11
gefordert haben damit stellen wir auch
für die betroffenen betriebe
größtmögliche transparenz her die
berechnung des pauschalierung satzes in
paragraf 24 umsatzsteuergesetz hat in
der sachverständigenanhörung auch für
diskussionen gesorgt die einbeziehung
von unternehmen die berechnung die jetzt
nicht mehr zu einem begünstigen zählen
wird möglicherweise für die betroffenen
betriebe zu nachteilen ebenso führt die
umstellung des pauschalierung satzes
während des laufenden wirtschaftsjahres
zu erheblichen buchführungs relevanten
problemen bei künftigen
gesetzgebungsverfahren sollten diese
umstände mehr bedacht werden und für
frühzeitige parlamentarische verfahren
sorgen des weiteren wird mit dem gesetz
für bestimmte einführungen und
lieferungen als reaktion auf die
corvette 19 pandemie eine
steuerbefreiung eingeführt auch diese
anpassung wird von uns freien demokraten
begrüßt wir werden natürlich unserem
gesetzentwurf zustimmen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
als nächste erhält das wort für die
spd-fraktion die kollegin jon chu step
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die anpassung der umsatzsteuer
für unsere landwirtinnen und landwirte
ist dringend notwendig das thema wurde
in den vergangenen jahren leider immer
wieder verschleppt und die verantwortung
hierfür trägt die cdu/csu-fraktion und
da hilft es auch nicht wie sie auch in
der anhörung sich versuchen als
opposition zu inszenieren
denn
eins ist klar wenn wir jetzt nicht
handeln dann drohen rückzahlungen der
bauern in höhe von bis zu zwei
milliarden euro und genau mit diesem
gesetz wollen wir das eu
vertragsverletzungsverfahren und das
beihilfeverfahren
abwenden und für die sicherheit unserer
landwirte sorgen wir als spd-fraktion
wollen unsere bauern schützen
und dafür werden wir den pauschale
steuersatz von gegenwärtig 10 10 7 auf
9,5 absenken wir folgen damit auf dem
weg vom bundesrechnungshof und von der
kommission dieser weg ist der richtige
weg und wir schaffen dabei auch nicht
nur rechtssicherheit wir nutzen auch den
spielraum aus den uns die mehrwertsteuer
richtlinie gibt wir arbeiten also im
sinne der kleinen und mittleren landwirt
in unserem artikel
umso mehr müssen wir vor den märchen der
union warnen die cdu csu scheint an
politischer demenz zu leiden mit
scheinargumenten wird hier kritisiert
die berechnungsmethode dass diese
methode federführend aus dem ministerium
vom hause frau klöckner kommt scheinen
sie folgerungen vergessen zu haben
auch dass die noch geschäftsführende
minister von cdu und csu kabinett
zugestimmt haben scheint sich in ihrer
erinnerung in luft aufgelöst zu haben ob
sie sich noch erinnern dass sie ja märz
mehrfach erfolglos auf ihren
parteivorsitz beworben hat sei mal dahin
gestellt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der union
ihre kritik am vorliegenden
gesetzesentwurf zeigt lediglich 1 sie
haben die gefahren des europäischen
vertragsverletzungsverfahrens nicht
ernst genommen sie haben mit unseren
landwirten im wahlkampf gespielt und sie
scheinen das ganze weiterhin auch nicht
ernst zu nehmen das ist fatal
sie können sich bei den bauern
vielleicht als engelchen der landwirt
aufspielen aber eben sind sie doch das
teufelchen dass die landwirte die zeche
zahlen lässt das wollen wir nämlich
nicht und um genau das zu verhindern
wird das gesetz zum ersten januar in
kraft treten uns ist bewusst dass dies
eine herausforderung für unsere
betroffenen landwirtinnen und landwirte
ist doch die eine ist eben notwendig
jede weitere verzögerung würde
signalisieren dass deutschland weiterhin
das europäische recht nicht anerkennen
will und das wollen wir nicht
hier in spd stehen zu europa bestehen
zum schutz unserer bauern und zu unserer
verantwortung lassen sie endlich diese
spielchen und stimmen sie heute diesem
gesetz zu vielen dank
dieser gesetzentwurf war auch schon im
hauptamt im hauptausschuss der empfiehlt
diesen entwurf so anzunehmen vorher
haben wir allerdings noch so einige
redner hier angekündigt sebastian bremen
spricht jetzt für die unionsfraktion
eine
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
die neue regierung aus spd grünen und
fdp ist noch nicht einmal im amt und
schon geht es mit dem ersten
gesetzentwurf aus dem hause olaf scholz
den kleinen bäuerlichen strukturen an
den kragen
mit der heutigen absenkung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der pauschale
steuersatz von 10 7 auf 9,5 prozent
kommt es zu einem effektiven realen
einkommensverlust dieser betriebe und
diese einkommensverlust beträgt im monat
bis zu 600 euro und kann übrigens nicht
kompensiert werden weil die
lebensmittelpreise fixiert sind weil die
kosten steigen zb für energie für
kraftstoffe wenn sie jetzt die
mindestlohn noch einführen auf 12 euro
wollte sich noch einmal verschärfen das
heißt teilweise sind diese kleinen
betriebe nur noch im nebenerwerb zu
führen was ist aus ihren programmen das
sind wahlprogrammen geworden liebe
koalitionäre die spd schreibt die partei
bekennt sich zu fairen preisen für
hochwertige nahrungsmittel die grünen
schreiben bäuerinnen und bauern müssen
von ihrer arbeit leben und faire
bezahlung von landwirtinnen freundin
erfordern sie die fdp sagt deutschland
braucht eine zukunftsorientierte
landwirtschaft die sich rechnet
also heute machen sie genau das
gegenteil worum geht es im einzelnen
es geht um paragraf 24
umsatzsteuergesetz kleine landwirte bis
600.000 euro umsatz können aus
bürokratie vereinfachungsgründen 10 7
prozent pauschale mehrwertsteuer in
rechnung stellen haben keinen
vorsteuerabzug die buchführungspflicht
igge unternehmen und deswegen ist ihre
märchen dass sie gerade erzählt dann
völlig falsch wenn sie den satz senken
dann senken sie automatisch auch die
einnahmen der kleinen und mittleren
bäuerlichen betriebe
natürlich wissen wir dass ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen
deutschland angestrebt worden ist von
der eu und dass wir die privilegierung
eine mögliche privilegierung dieser
betriebe prüfen müssen also eine
besserstellung ansonsten käme es zu
rückforderungen der landwirtschaft
gerade für die kleinen mittleren
betriebe und es wäre natürlich zu
verhindern aber die frage wurde von der
koalition eingebracht um eben dann mit
einer berechnung zu prüfen ob überhaupt
eine privilegierung vorliegt und diese
berechnung ist nicht aus dem
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium sondern
diese berechnungen müsste aus dem
bundesfinanzministerium kommen und liegt
nicht vor die haben wir mehrmals
angefordert selbst in der anhörung haben
die sogar ihnen sage ich mal eher
zugeneigten experten gesagt dass es im
transparent ist und dass die berechnung
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar ist das
heißt sie wissen gar nicht ob der satz
gesenkt werden soll oder ob vielleicht
das hat sogar steigt weil mich die ganze
gruppe der landwirte durch die absenkung
auf 600.000 euro vielleicht dazu führen
dass dieser satz sich sogar erhöhen
könnte also insofern haben sie
handwerklich absolut schlechte arbeit
geleistet sie haben die bauern
bewusst aus meiner sicht bewusst
geschädigt und ich sage ihnen eins wenn
sie jetzt auch noch weitermachen mit dem
agrar diesel den sie abschaffen wollen
wenn sie noch die angekündigten
subventionen abschaffen wollen dann ist
es eben nichts mehr mit der bäuerlichen
nahversorgung dann ist es auch nichts
mehr mit der ökologischen vielfalt die
sie so fordern dann wird es zu einer
industrialisierung der landwirtschaft
führen und die kleineren und mittleren
betriebe werden aussterben liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist die
wahrheit ich glaube sie haben noch nie
einen jahresabschluss ich glaube sie
haben noch nie einen jahresabschluss
eines kleineren und mittleren bauern
gesehen sie machen das doch alles
theoretisch schauen sie sich doch das
mal an sie haben null komma null
empathie sie haben null komma null
respekt vor den kleinen und mittleren
landwirten sie machen sie mit diesem
gesetz kaputt und die fdp fungiert zum
ersten mal wieder als erhöhungs partei
als steuererhöhungspartei wir lehnen
diesen gesetzentwurf heute ab mit einem
klaren signal an die landwirtschaft wir
stehen zu den kleinen bäuerlichen
betrieben und wir wollen ihre strukturen
auch erhalten herzlichen dank
eine sehr deutliche kritik aus der
unionsfraktion
hierzu den
[Musik]
entwurf eines gesetzes zur umsetzung sie
uns rechtlicher form ihr leder im
umsatzsteuerrecht tag erhält jetzt die
kollegin doktor ophelia nick von bündnis
90 die grünen das wort
sehr geehrte präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich freue mich
ausserordentlich hier heute in diesem
haus sprechen zu dürfen und ich wünsche
uns für die kommenden vier jahre
mut und entschlossenheit die lösung der
vielen drängenden probleme anzugehen
denn da ist viel liegen geblieben
[Applaus]
es fehlt heute um die anpassung der
umsatzsteuerpauschalierung in der
landwirtschaft das klingt vielleicht für
manche sehr technisch aber es bedeutet
für viele bäuerinnen bauern konkrete
schmerzhafte einschnitte im nächsten
jahr und die bundesregierung hat einen
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt der den
durchschnittssatz der
umsatzsteuerpauschalierung in der
landwirtschaft von derzeit 10,7 prozent
auf 9,5 prozent absenkt und die
landwirtinnen die geben mehr als umsatz
von 600.000 haben die müssen dann in die
regelbesteuerung wechseln und das
ausgangs problem das haben wir ja nicht
hier erzeugt sondern dass man ein
klageverfahren war französische
milchviehhalter und schweine erzeuger
gegen eine ungleichbehandlung beklagt
hatten und dann hat die eu das angemahnt
und es wurde eine prüfung eingeleitet
meine damen und herren diese anpassungen
lassen sich eben vor diesem hintergrund
einfach nicht mehr vermeiden und wenn
wir jetzt auch noch weiter verzögern
dann würden wir sogar die pauschalierung
von den betrieben die unter 600.000 sind
auch noch gefährden und das wollen wir
ja nicht machen von daher ist es ein
kompromiss
und ja sie mit ihren kollegen ist fehlen
95 millionen jetzt auf den betrieben und
es sind die betriebe die hohe
wertschöpfung haben es sind vier
haltende betriebe und es sind die
betriebe mit sonder kultur und dazu
kommt ja dass die einkommenssituation
auf vielen landwirtschaftlichen
betrieben ja wirklich gerade extrem
angespannt ist wir wissen dass von den
vier haltenden betrieben und jetzt eben
auch in der schweinebranche die schwaben
corona die schweinebranche hat die
afrikanische schweinepest sie ist
hochansteckend sie tödlich und sie
besorgt uns alle sehr und das drückt den
betrieben
und deshalb schließen viele ihre hoftore
und zwar in den letzten zehn jahren 13
prozent der landwirtschaftlichen
betriebe haben zugemacht und es waren
überproportional davon vier haltende
betriebe
22% man muss sich mal vorstellen das
wäre in einer anderen branche was wäre
denn da eigentlich los bei
betrieben bei bauernhöfen da ist das
eben oft sehr leise und die tierzahlen
die sind aber nicht gesungen können ich
habe ja gesagt viele tierhaltenden
betriebe haben beschlossen die tier
zahlen sind nicht gesunden sondern die
sind in andere stelle gegangen die sind
größer und voller geworden und dass das
können wir doch hier alle nicht wollen
wir brauchen sie brauchen die
familienbetriebe wenn wir den umbau der
landwirtschaft zu mehr nachhaltigkeit
regionale erzeugung und tierwohl
voranbringen wollen und deshalb ist es
gut dass wir die pauschalisierung für
kleinere betriebe erhalten werden und
deswegen stimmen wir grüne auf jeden
fall gemeinsam mit spd und fdp und ich
hoffe auch anderen dieser diesem
gesetzesvorschlag
zugelegt ich habe einen bezug zur
landwirtschaft ich denke auch
unternehmerisch und bäuerliche betriebe
die wollen auch unternehmerisch handeln
können aber zum unternehmertum hört es
eben auch dass die gesellschaftlichen
anforderungen auf den höfen integriert
werden und das bedeutet klimaschutz das
bedeutet biodiversität das bedeutet
tierwohl und da müssen wir die politik
die landwirtschaft begleiten und da
warne ich
davor
aus der alten koalition bleiben und die
probleme in die zukunft verschieben die
wir dann hier auf dem tisch haben würde
auf den teller um im bild zu bleiben wir
müssen nun endlich zum handeln kommen
und das handeln das ist eben auch unser
ziel dass wir zum beispiel wertschöpfung
durch qualität eben für bäuerinnen und
bauern herrn wir brauchen gesundes essen
in den regionen wir brauchen regionale
versorgung und wir haben heute über eine
ausbau der ganztagsbetreuung gesprochen
das kann uns ja auch nicht egal sein was
kinder und jugendliche auf ihrem teller
haben auch da ist wirklich viel zu tun
dass es liegen geblieben
ja
aufgetrieben und das weiss ich mich
haben viele schon die letzte woche
angerufen es ist eine angespannte
finanzielle situation auf den höfen wir
haben hohe gesellschaftliche
anforderungen wir wollen die planetaren
grenzen einhalten und damit können wir
nicht die landwirtschaft alleine lassen
und wir grüne wir stellen uns an die
seite der bäuerinnen und bauern und
wollen sie bei den herausforderungen
unterstützen und begleiten und das
lassen sie uns doch bitte in den
nächsten jahren gemeinsam machen
verantwortung übernehmen und beschallten
denn es geht um die wertschätzung der
menschen die eben unsere teller voll
machen und deshalb leidenschaftlich will
ich mir für die belange der
landwirtschaft einsetzen und bedanke
musste ja für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
bis 90 die grünen die linksfraktion und
die fdp fraktion haben wir jeweils
anträge eingereicht die fdp fraktion hat
einen änderungsantrag hier eingereicht
in dem diese fordert diese absetzung des
durchschnitts satzes zu verschieben und
zwar um ein halbes jahr auf dem ersten
juli 2022 und für die fw fraktion
spricht jetzt klaus stuber
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich möchte schon wundern über die
äußerung die jetzt bisher so süßen
gesetzesentwurf verlautet worden wir
können froh sein dass die landwirte
wahrscheinlich und dieser tageszeit
arbeiten müssen das nicht hören müssen
sie sollen sie wahrscheinlich sie
vorwerfen vor lauter verzweiflung
denn wenn man hier sagt vertritt die
interessen der landwirtschaft und dann
gleichzeitig mit 95 milliarden millionen
neu belastet das passt ganz zusammen der
kollege görke sie hatten ja
der letzten woche angemerkt ich würde
also unsere fraktion you pasching
betreiben das kann ich natürlich so
nicht bestätigen
ich denke mal die eu hat ja genügend
aufgaben diese endlich erfüllen könnte
im wirtschafts kampf mit russland usa
oder china aber sie konzentriert sich
darauf aus mit bürokratie zu überlasten
insbesondere auch hier den landwirten
das leben schwer zu machen
vielleicht sollte ein oder haben wir mal
den hyde verinnerlichen den kanzler
minister oder auch wieder als bundestags
abgeleistet haben zum wohle des
deutschen volkes seinen nutzen mehren
schaden von ihm abwenden
da steht nichts von europa hallo
inhaltlich über europa sprechen
besonderen uns über die fakten
unterhalten hatte letzte woche in meiner
rede schon bemängelt dass das tempo mit
dem das gesetz verabschiedet wird
unangemessen hoch ist dass sie hat da
auch in der anhörung am montag bei die
sachverständigen war es genau das
hauptthema am arten helfen wollen die
verbände angehört am fünften mussten sie
schon eine stellungnahme abgeben muss
innerhalb von 24 stunden die mündliche
anhörung erfolgte am 15 november und am
pult am 18 november soll das gesetz
bereits verabschiedet und erster hassen
2022 in kraft treten das ist ja ein
landwirtschaftliches thema ist könnte
man auch salopp sagen das gesetz soll im
schweinsgalopp durch die gremien
gepeitscht werden wenn ich dann im
entwurf lese dass die kosten für die
internen kosten übernehmen wir bei der
umsetzung bei 180 tausend fällen gerade
bei 170000 euro liegen soll muss ich
schon lachen ja das kann mir jemand
geschrieben haben der förderpraxis keine
ahnung hat denn es soll die
gesetzesänderung löste sich auch einiges
raus die rechnungslegung muss geändert
werden die buchführungs programme müssen
angepasst werden es müssen verträge
tarik wurden geprüft werden natürlich
zur neuen umsatzsteuer und müssen die
jedenfalls auch angepasst werden und es
muss vielleicht auch sogar externe
beratung herangezogen werden das alles
in drei minuten für ein europa das ist
schon sehr realitätsfremd deshalb haben
wir ein änderungsantrag eingebracht der
vorsieht dass diese änderung nicht zum
rassenhass
2022 zu rasten sie und 2022 in kraft
treten soll das wurde auch komfort und
geben den abweichenden wirtschaftsjahr
weil ich die meisten landwirte anwenden
diese möglichkeit wurde auch
gleichzeitig die möglichkeit eröffnen
das waren 2 die kritik bolaño am montag
dass die berechnungsgrundlage des durch
des staates angepasst wird denn es kann
nur die unternehmen eingezogen werden ja
wirklich unter 600.000 euro umsatz
liegen das ist im moment nicht der fall
meine damen und herren ich war es bei
anträgen gehe ich zum schluss heißt der
letzte satz danke es geht hier nicht um
migration oder corona ist unser land
worte deswegen bin ich aus
qualitätsgründen diesen antrag
zuzustimmen vielen dank
für die fraktion die linke hält das wort
der eben angesprochene kollege christian
görke
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das wir heute auf den letzten
drücker über ein gesetz sprechen dass
die buchhaltung die kalkulation der
landwirte zum ersten januar in sechs
wochen in ein karussell wurde hat allein
damit zu tun dass die alte
bundesregierung sich nicht getraut hat
vor der wahl zu handeln seit jahren
liebe kolleginnen kollegen ist dieses
problem bekannt schon im zuge des
letzten jahres steuergesetzes wo die
hier darüber diskutiert und jetzt muss
ein handwerklich schlechter
gesetzentwurf innerhalb von einer woche
durchgedrückt werden und dass es ein
armutszeugnis und liebe kollegen
kollegen der spd fraktion aber auch der
cdu csu fraktion dafür tragen sie die
verantwortung nach wie vor interessant
ist aber dass der gesetzentwurf die
politische farbenlehre hier wirklich
durcheinander wirbelt die cdu csu
fraktion kritisiert den entwurf den sie
noch mit ihrer landwirtschaftsministerin
am tenor landwirtschaftsministerin mit
dem grünen stift eingebracht hat und
sehr geehrter herr kollege bremen
konstruktive opposition dann müssen sie
wirklich noch lernen aber noch besser
ist ja die performance der fdp da
zitiere ich meine kollegin linda mit uns
keine steuererhöhungen und genau das
heißt der gesetzentwurf aber durch die
hintertür dennoch seite 2 steht schwarz
auf weiß 22 20 22 80 millionen und satte
190 millionen mehreinnahmen pro jahr bis
25 also steuererhöhungen abgesehen dass
sie bei dem portal ihre kleinen land
wurden hierhin greifen was ich nicht für
angemessen halte halte ich doch
steuererhöhungen für durchaus vernünftig
denn wir werden natürlich auch über die
finanzierung der kindergrundsicherung
beidrehen und liebe kollegen der spd und
der grünen da die fdp sich jetzt im
koalitionsbett schon fast am horizont
sind ein bisschen sich schon flexibel
zeit haben sie den mut machen sie noch
mal druck vielleicht bewegen sie sich
auch bei der vermögenssteuer denn die
brauchen wir in den ländern um die
bildungsinfrastruktur zu finanzieren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
kritik der links fraktion am
gesetzentwurf hat sich auch in einer
woche nicht geändert er der
pauschalisierung satz ist falsch
berechnet er belastet die kleinen land
wurde erst lebensfremd weil das
wirtschaftsjahr landwirte wie sie wissen
vom juli bis juni geht das gesetz
handwerklich schlecht gemacht und
insofern an der praxis vorbei ich werbe
für unseren entschließungsantrag vielen
dank
vielen dank
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist noch
ein mitglied des hauses anwesend dass
seine stimme noch nicht abgegeben hat
das ist ganz offensichtlich der fall sie
haben jetzt noch die eine redezeit
und dafür erhält das wort die
abgeordnete susanne mittag für die spd
fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin der geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir reden heute war wieder ein thema das
längst schon hätte geregelt und
abgestimmt werden müssen das kennen wir
schon von der umsetzung der nitrat
richtlinie regelung in der sauenhaltung
beim kastenstand beendigung des küken
tötens bei den gesetzlichen regelungen
zu tierversuchen und der betäubungslosen
ferkelkastration
gesetze werden einfach nicht umgesetzt
oder so lange blockiert und verzögert
bis gerichte oder
vertragsverletzungsverfahren der eu
kommission maßnahmen vorschreiben und
die bisherige ministerin immer zum
handeln zwang und wenn es dann so weit
ist gibt es jede menge aufregung bei den
beteiligten nachvollziehbarerweise weil
die fristen so kurz die
handlungsspielräume durch den endstand
in den standen den zeitdruck absolut
gelingt werden und so ist es auch im
vorliegenden fall es geht die vom land
wird gewünscht um eine steuerliche
vereinfachungen die den buchführungs-
und verwaltungsaufwand der landwirte
verringert aber nicht einen finanziellen
zugewinn bedeuten soll diese
ausnahmeregelung ist ein
landwirtschaftliches
alleinstellungsmerkmal und bedarf nach
jahren denn der anpassung das hat nicht
nur der bundesrechnungshof bereits 2009
10 gefordert sondern weil das
landwirtschaftsministerium
offensichtlich immer noch nicht reagiert
hat die eu kommission inzwischen ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren und
parallel anhängig ein beihilfe
rechtliches verfahren angestrengt aber
das war ja nicht das einzige laufende
verfahren in dem ministerium und wenn
wir nicht bis zum 31.12 fristgerecht
handeln und anpassen dann wird es nicht
nur für unseren haushalt kostenträchtig
es besteht dazu noch die möglichkeit
dass steuerliche rückforderung rücken
bis zu zehn jahren auf die landwirte zu
kommen frau kollegin erlauben sie eine
zwischenfrage aus der afg fraktion nein
es besteht noch die möglichkeit dass
steuerliche förderung rückwirkend damit
sich das jeder mal viel gegenwert sich
der dann immer für landwirte ist auf die
landwirte zu kommen aber am ende muss es
trotzdem noch geändert werden denn die
nicht anpassung führt zu steuerausfällen
in unserem haushalt und damit zu
jahrelang ungerechtfertigten vor
ungerechtfertigten steuervorteilen für
die landwirte was die landwirte aber
überhaupt nicht beabsichtigt haben
damit hat mit sicherheit kein
pauschalierende landwirt gerechnet wie
denn auch und derartige nachteile zu
verhindern ist doch aufgabe auch eines
landwirtschaftsministeriums
in der anhörung am montag war die
notwendigkeit der anpassung und strittig
es gab auch noch vorschläge den
zeitpunkt der anpassung für das
wirtschaftsjahr auszurichten also zur
jahresmitte das ist ein beachtenswerter
aspekt da er sich aber durch die
verfahrens verschleppung des
landwirtschaftsministerium inzwischen
auch erledigt hat die zeit reicht
einfach nicht mehr es ist mir daher
völlig schleierhaft warum die anpassung
nicht schon 2019 2020 oder in diesem
jahr bis zur sommerpause vom
landwirtschaftsministerium zusammen mit
dem finanzministerium vorgelegt wurde
aber nein das landwirtschaftsministerium
hat die bildvorlage blockiert und das
hat wahrscheinlich auch nichts mit einem
wahltermin zu tun es ist ja schon wie
gesagt ein gesetzentwurf den wir
grundsätzlich inhaltlich auch übernommen
haben ich bin gespannt wie die
cdu/csu-fraktion sich dazu verhält ob
sie mit stimmen ob sie unser aller
haushalt nicht mit strafzahlungen
belasten wollen und die landwirte
rechtssicherer vor rückforderungen zu
bewahren und ihr versäumnis zu heilen
oder ob sie sich weiter zum verhalten
als könnte durch ignorieren eine zu
erfüllende rechtsvorschrift einfach aus
dieser welt verschwinden herzlichen dank
das wort erhält für eine
kurzintervention der kollege der afg
herr gottschalk
vielen dank frau präsidentin frau
kollegin mittag gestatten sie mir
einfach zwei zwischenfragen ich habe so
ein bisschen das gefühl die spd-fraktion
leidet kollegial an partiellen amnesie
der erste frage war eigentlich etwa oder
ist seit drei jahren finanzminister der
bundesrepublik deutschland und hat
dieses ressort zu verantworten und das
was sie eben beklagt haben diese
verantwortungslosigkeit gegenüber den
landwirten oder aber auch einfach
schlamp hat formuliert das versäumnis
ähnlich wie bei wirecard bei der bafin
und bei anderen dingen da war herr
scholz ja auch ganz vorne also nennen
sie mir kurz den namen des
bundesfinanzministers und wer in dieser
zeit für das ressort verantwortlich war
und ist ihm vielleicht bekannt
vielleicht ist ihnen das auch in dieser
partiellen amnesie entfallen das ist ein
schreiben vom 21 08 diesen jahres 20 21
gibt vom bundesrechnungshof in diesem
schreiben räumt der bundesrechnungshof
sehr großzügig ein da bin ich sogar mal
ausnahmsweise bei der linken da fällt
mir so gar kein zacken aus der krone und
auch bei unserem kollegen klaus stöber
der dazu anmahnt sich zeit zu lassen
denn in diesem schreiben räumt der
bundesrechnungshof ein mann ließ uns
zeit immerhin bis zum ersten ersten 20
23 verehrte kollegin also noch nicht mal
zum ersten ersten nächsten jahres
sondern 23 so und wenn sie mir die
fragen beantworten könnten wäre ich
schon sehr glücklich vielleicht kann das
ein bisschen dem zustand und
schockzustand dass die
regierungsverantwortung bei ihm vor der
tür steht helfen und die amnesie
auflösen vielen dank frau kollegin
antworten
bitte das eine ist teilweise ist die
frage schon beantwortet worden in der
anhörung das zweite ist die hälfte der
anfrage gehört gar nicht zum thema und
das dritte ist wenn sie zugehört hätten
hätten sie sich selber beantworten
können
soweit die kurzintervention und die
reaktionen darauf und damit kommen wir
zum letzten redner in dieser debatte
artur auernhammer ist das von der
unionsfraktion und augen gegangen weil
wir müssen ja die namentliche abstimmung
noch schließen nicht so also ist noch
ein ist noch ein mitglied im hause
anwesend das noch nicht abgestimmt hat
das scheint nicht der fall zu sein ich
schließe die abstimmung und bitte die
schriftführerin und schriftführer mit
der auszählung zu beginnen das ergebnis
der abstimmung wird ihnen dann später
bekanntgegeben und nunmehr erhält der
abgeordnete artur auernhammer
entschuldigung für die cdu csu das wort
bitte schön
liebe frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die kollegin
mittag hat gerade auch viele punkte
aufgeführt die in der letzten
legislaturperiode
auch hier im deutschen bundestag beraten
haben sie hat aber nicht gesagt dass
sehr viele belastungen die wir den
landwirten und den bauernfamilien
zugemutet haben aus dem
bundesumweltministerium gekommen sind
das muss man auch zur vollständigkeit
hier sein und wenn es wenn es heute um
die umsatzsteuerpauschalierung geht dann
ist das auch ein abbau des
bürokratieabbaus viele von uns
verwenden in ihren sonntagsreden oft das
wort bürokratieabbau und gerade in der
landwirtschaft haben wir mit der
umsatzsteuerpauschalierung ein ideales
instrument und grad kleinbäuerlichen
betrieben diese last der bürokratie zu
nehmen wir entlassen hier gerade
tierhaltungsbetriebe nehmer was betriebe
weinbaubetriebe gemüsebaubetriebe die
werden von dieser bürokratie entlastet
und es ist eine gute installation diese
umsatzsteuerpauschalierung und nicht
umsonst
werden zwei drittel der deutschen
betriebe dieses instrument nutzen aber
wenn wir jetzt den mehrwertsteuersatz
von 10 7 auf 9,5 senken werden weil es
dazu kommen dass wieder mehr betriebe in
die regelbesteuerung einsteigen müssen
dass sie höhere auflagen haben dass sie
mehr arbeit haben dass immer mehr
bürokratie haben dass die steuerberater
mehrarbeit habe um das auch unsere
finanzbehörden wesentlich mehr arbeit
haben also bürger die sich bei mir
anders aus meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren die anhörung hat auch gezeigt
dass die nachvollziehbarkeit der
berechnung nicht so richtig gegeben ist
und diese berechnung kommt aus dem
bundesfinanzministerium also diesen
vorhof zum kanzleramt momentan und diese
ist anscheinend nicht korrekt genug und
nicht nachvollziehbar und deshalb
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
sollten wir auch die ergebnisse dieser
anhörung noch mal analysieren nochmal
genau darauf schauen und ein punkt ist
mir auch besonders wichtig das ist der
erste siebte wir haben eben in der
landwirtschaft ein wirtschaftsjahres
beginnt am ersten siebter und herren 30
06 auf das hat etwas mit natur mit
wachstum zu tun und deshalb finde ich
hier ist auch gut und ich finde es schon
gerade von den grünen etwas ja
merkwürdig wenn man hier krokodilstränen
vergießen ich zitiere die kollegin pause
von der ersten lesung und ja es wird
wieder diejenigen treffen die heute
schon um ihr überleben kämpfen das recht
ja aber warum machen wir das dann warum
machen die das land und meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren der freistaat
bayern hat im bundesrat einen antrag
gestellt
dass die verluste die durch diese
reduzierten mehrwertsteuersätze
ausgeglichen werden in der
landwirtschaftlichen
berufsgenossenschaft in der
landwirtschaft sozial genug leider haben
wir auch hier die grünen nicht
mitgemacht und hat auch hier die ampel
koalition versagt meine damen und herren
wir reden hier von einer mehrbelastung
für unsere bauernfamilien von 100
millionen euro im jahr und ich möchte
ihn nicht ausmalen was noch auf uns
zukommt was auf die bauernfamilien in
deutschland zukommt mit dieser ampel
koalition richtig ans arbeiten kommt
wenn wir wissen was im koalitionsvertrag
steht ich kann ihnen zu sichern wir
werden hier sehr genau hinschauen und
ihnen nicht alles durchgehen lassen und
in diesem sinne vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
also diesmal wäre noch redezeit da
gewesen aber der redner war leider schon
fertig also keine zwischenfrage ich
schließe die aussprache wir kommen zur
abstimmung über den von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur umsetzung unions
rechtlicher vorgaben im
umsatzsteuerrecht der hauptausschuss
empfiehlt in seiner beschlussempfehlung
auf drucksache 75 den gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung auf drucksache 12
anzunehmen es liegt ein änderungsantrag
der fraktion der afg auf drucksache 91
vor wer stimmt dafür in diesem
änderungsantrag fordert die fdp fraktion
dass diese
umsatzsteuersatz erst zum ersten juli
angepasst wird im jahr 2022
der änderungsantrag wurde aber abgelehnt
und damit kommen wir jetzt zur
abstimmung über den gesetzentwurf
das sind spd bündnis 90 die grünen und
die fdp wer stimmt dagegen
das sind alle übrigen fraktionen also
die linke cdu csu und afg enthaltung
keine der gesetzentwurf ist damit in
zweiter beratung angenommen dritte
beratung und schlussabstimmung ich bitte
diejenigen die den gesetzentwurf
zustimmen wollen sich zu erheben
das sind wieder die spd die grünen und
die fdp wer stimmt dagegen
dass die linke cdu csu und die fdp
enthält sich der gesetzentwurf ist somit
angenommen damit haben also die ampel
koalition ihre bzw die sind ja noch an
den sondierungsgesprächen
zugestimmt also wird der umsatzsteuer
durchschnittssatz für land und
forstwirtschaftliche betriebe ab dem
nächsten jahr von 10 7 auf 9,5 prozent
gesenkt es gibt noch einen
entschließungsantrag der linken in dem
auch die linksfraktion fordert dass eben
dieser stichtag für diese anpassung
nicht am ersten januar sondern am ersten
juli ist der wurde allerdings auch
abgestimmt